hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back you beautiful lovely
people there CP containment breach why
am i coddling you so early it's because
it was a bit of a problem it was a
memory access violation on the last save
which is very unfortunate because I was
very far into it and I'm very upset but
I'm not gonna take that out on you
gorgeous people you so what I'm gonna do
is there's this new feature that allows
people to create their own Maps and then
was this example map in here so I'm
gonna give it a try I think I've already
use that so let's give this a go to see
what awaits us in the darkness beyond
I bet this example map is just like
there's gonna be 10,000 scp-173 s in
front of me and they're all gonna kill
me dead
actually I don't see how they could
unless I blink I'm gonna kill each other
they're gonna do ok so this is the
example map but I doubt it's gonna be
very much different all it means is that
oh well that's what another thing you
can't do this way I don't even have a
thing thing you're not obeying the rules
all right I guess I got a slark through
it dying with my eyes a flutter okay let
me just wait until my eyes clear up or
I'd go out there those death await me oh
good morning well this is what happens
when they can make their own map it's
not left up to chance anymore well well
well what do we have here let's see I
don't have a gas mask I don't have it I
don't have that I don't have it you need
to give it to me oh god it's just a
series of tubes series of tubes they
leave the 911 for great fantastic I
gotta go through the cloudy room why are
they trying to blind my eyes I think
this example map was made by the Creator
so this is the first time that he saved
many blue make his own no one in there
okay I'm gonna take that on faith okay
all right
blink blink blink blink blink it out of
your eyes okay there we go okay well as
that nice isn't that just lovely oh
goody maybe I can get a key card yes I
can Oh level two things are going
wonderfully for me so now I can go back
to 9/11 for I'm not gonna cheat Wow
it's right here
ah okay I'm done all right that's creepy
I'm gonna get out of here I'm gonna head
back and try to get to 9 1 4 which means
it hanging let me see what's over here
before I go all away okay just the
hallway yeah go back 1 7 3 is not there
I heard him scraping around in the
beginning but apparently that's not
something that I need to concern myself
with get out of my eyes get away
ok look at away come on blink it away
there we go alright go 9 1 4
where is you which way did I go why did
my camera just zip around hey where was
9 1 4 and what was down there I don't
know I think this is the way I came
mister why I came is the way that I want
for oh wait no that's back to the
beginning that's right okay there's the
only reason I'm going here is to make
this key card back okay this might take
a while I'm gonna fast-forward through
this you guys don't have to deal with it
whoa okay all right
apparently I can't get past a level
three but that don't matter
because the level three will allow me to
get everything that I could possibly
need right mumbo jumbo okay so I don't
have a gas mask but 173 doesn't seem to
be bothering me the fact that 173 is not
but the fact that 173 is not bothering
me is actually bothering me worse than
it he was not bothering me to go no I've
gone cross-eyed okay
so what we have here is a failure to
communicate
hey now in this one nothing is random
everything is planned
the only question why did you talk like
a [ __ ]
[Music]
ah I need a higher level I can get this
one
oh is this wait this is the Encyclopedia
diseases I do not need that I'm gonna
drop that on the floor turn around and
never come back
maybe if I have it on me and those MTF
are chasing me I can drop it on the
floor of the bay like whoa look at book
how dare they enjoy no box at my
eyeballs and then no no but I highly
doubt that the thing maybe if I put it
in nine one four I'll carry what Matt
just won't read it
maybe if I ever want to commit suicide I
will read it ah I don't need to go here
I need to contain you but I don't want
to contain you
I don't wanna you're my friend but there
is another key card in here that I do
need that is very true I just remembered
that well-well-well radical Larry it
seems that you are suddenly becoming
very useful to me okay
sound transmission one
oh wait no what what no no contain it
yet I need that off wait what now get
off mom I need him to be able to get in
there all right now yeah oh yeah oh yeah
buddy yeah there's someone out here I
love you girls let me know
where's what where's where's radical
Larry
[Music]
where's radical Larry
Oh
there's radical Larry all right time to
reboot you bum
I'm gonna just turn that sound
transmission off and we're gonna go
about our daily life and where's the
card
ah come on wasn't there before
all right I just killed that guy for
nothing
what oh that's over there no Nina I
always feel bad about that one it's a
good horrific multiple ways in multiple
ways that is horrific our radical Larry
have fun in there forever
will you die until you die
okay so now there's more doors to go
down everything is so closely contained
in here and fairly brightly lit in here
it's almost cheerful makes me happy
makes me happy to see and I'm gonna see
it another day oh boy no boy I can't
wait to go about my life and not die in
horrible agony oh god I've dumped
I need those kinda maybe I don't know
let me battery akitoki I have that no I
did okay I do need batteries that's
right they didn't I didn't make super
versions of these Pato Pato okay there
we go
couldn't connect the database but that
don't matter because I'm mapping out it
as we speak
okay so so far so good
I like this Gus
man
facility
I don't think that's the thing that
you're gonna be doing cuz I think you're
kind of a son of a [ __ ] oh wait a
minute wait is this car wait where did I
get that where did I get that
where did I get that level four where
did I get that oh maybe I picked it up
off the table huh you creepy ass okay
now I got a hazmat suit that's good
kinda I guess I guess so now that I got
that that means that I can do what I
want to do like what go absorb me some
viruses no I'm not gonna do that
so mobile task force did now in the
facility which means bad news for me but
I don't know if they came exactly
through this doorway I just got to keep
going it's really interesting when the
math is not random but it's also
designed by an evil maniacal person who
made this game very well what what yeah
what happened this guy just shoot
himself why would you know that
the but ghost convinced you to do that
where's the butt ghost the bug ghost
barely not here apparently well that
sucks for that guy
that's a Mook hi hi computer friend oh
I'm just gonna put on my hands man to
get on my merry way
I'm a little disconcerted Wow Sudan what
are you doing dad that suit on that used
to work but apparently a dozen where the
hell did 173 go I don't know I don't
know these things
oh my eyes are drew no what no no okay
so I don't know if there's anything down
here that I need oh there's a dead guy
he's got a level four damn it I already
out of Louisville for fighting on a
level four was in here before I would
have gotten it hello friend what what's
going on
I'm getting out of there okay I'm
getting out of there yeah I didn't look
at the thing no I'm not looking at not
looking at it seriously where the hell
is 173 that's what I want to know and
now what I want to know
friggin hazmat suit it don't work it
don't work don't work it doesn't work
why doesn't it work maybe it doesn't
function as a gas head I don't know
oh boy another one yes since it doesn't
work no point right no point I thought I
could get around them they seem to be
very preoccupied with the wall there
well damn it ah what am i doing when the
last time I saved I don't know oh good
right before I got in here wait did I oh
no way no that was there I don't need to
go down there I need to go back oh oh
those sons of [ __ ] those sons of
[ __ ]
sons of [ __ ]
why would that guy kill himself he was
almost safe-ish Iowa I would have
protected him we were to become best
friends and it would have been awesome I
hear you over there here either
I hear you what are you gonna do I think
these guys are stuck because they don't
know how to handle this so I'm gonna go
another way and come back at a later
date I have a level 4 security card I
don't know what that means for me but I
got it I can open this one now maybe I
need to drop this what was in here oh is
this 7 1 4 what did 7 1 4 do again was
it the one that protected me from the
pneumatic effects
find me you son of a [ __ ]
you bastard you gosh-dang bested I still
hear you what what open they somehow
coming through there I don't know how
they did but they did it god damn it
those bastards those bastards
whose business is trying to kill me
gotta kill me dead
I wish won 7-3 would come and say hi to
them somehow still managed to shoot me
in the face now I don't know how and I
don't know why but they did what I need
to do I'm gonna get this ring I may need
it for something read this it's deadly
oh boy
it's a hide hi I'm hi
nope we're doing what are they doing
you're not gonna save I'd be stupid hey
stop why did they are they still there
if I open the store will I die ha ha ha
ha
ah goddamn you son of a [ __ ] all right
that's all the time I got for this part
god damn it I really wasn't expecting
that
so anyway hahaha this is why this game
can still surprise me I didn't even see
one seven three that whole time but
didn't matter dare you nine-tailed Fox
anyway so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
Kludd